[Musik]
gute und böse geister begleiten die
menschen auf schritt und tritt im
hochland von kamerun
die schweizerin katharina handy trägt
den titel einer königin und lebt in
einer welt mit ahnenkult und mobil an
diesem coup platz steht der sohn rudolf
touch sk im mittelpunkt der voodoo
priester ist er bietet die geister der
ahnen den kleinen sky zu beschützen
das ist eine geschichte wie aus dem
märchen mit prinzen einer königin und
bösen mächten drei jahre zuvor
die arbeitslose verkäuferin katharina
handy aus dem bernischen moosseedorf
lernt im internet einen prinzen aus
kamerun kennen sie will ihn vom fleck
weg heiraten also ein zukünftiger könig
was ich erwartet hatte
seither nennt sie sich rein katharina
königin katharina im herbst 2005 wandert
katharina nach kamerun aus zum ersten
mal zieht sie ihren 45 jahre alten
prinzen in wirklichkeit schon bald folgt
die heirat nach alter sitte durch den
könig in bank ag
hier am hof des königs prinz basler
aufgewachsen sein inzwischen
verstorbener vater hat 150 frauen mit
denen er über 700 kinder zeugte
prinz master zeit nicht zu den
erstgeborenen den traum wird er wohl nie
besteigen der kroatischen könig blieb
prinz constantijn kartell nach honig war
denn news tag mehrere spritzen für prinz
bleibt das nur meter im herbst vor zwei
jahren wird aus dem königlichen paar
eine kleinfamilie
der sohn heißt rudolf tucek barolo und
ist natürlich ein wahrhafter prinz
anfang letzten jahres kehrt katharina
heinig ohne geld in die schweiz zurück
sie zieht bei ihren eltern ein
dies in der wohnungssuche weil ihnen
gekündigt wurde
katharina bezieht sozialhilfe und
versucht sich durch den verkauf von
afrikanischen gewürzen über wasser zu
halten
und sie versucht aus ihrem leben kapital
zu schlagen
bezirks wie sie sich aus probe kapitol
wo sie es geschickt und das natürlich
mit großem interesse seit sommer 2007
wohnt die weiße königin mit ihren eltern
in diesem wohnblock bei bern
der bau konvikt erinnerungen an afrika
aber dort war katharina zuletzt vor
sechs monaten
der kleine prinz bringt glück in das
neue daheim durch großvater rudolf handy
hat schlechte laune wegen des besuchs
afrika ist es eng in der ohnehin kleine
wohnung dass sie mehr im wohnzimmer
[Applaus]
wie gut sie ihre mobile sind jetzt am
sinn muss jedoch sagen ich spüre es gut
dass er nirgendwo umstritten
was fällt ihnen dann ja eigentlich alles
sicher einfach nur wie die klinsi die
vielen modernen das japanische witzel
die mit weniger abbas qualitäten als vor
ohne sich allzu oft gestellt die auf den
kopf gestellt ist auch katharinas leben
aus heiterem himmel brachte bringt sind
kamerun zusammen angeblich wegen
schwarzer magie unter herzproblemen und
das macht das vorhaben berührt
das geht ja wenige tage danach zieht des
katharina mit sohn erneut nach afrika
ihre man geht es zu diesem zeitpunkt
wieder besser
die schweiz hatte sozialstaat afrika
ruft erneut
in der zwischenzeit läuft der abenteuer
durch die druckmaschinen
das buch ist in zusammenarbeit mit einer
co-autorin entstanden
schwarzer prinz weise königin erzählt
die schweizerisch-amerikanische
lovestory das erste druckfrische
exemplar ist für verlagsleiter lukas
heim bestimmt etwas leer geworden bei
den handys so ganz ohne enkel kennt doch
nun will das 80 jahre auf der ehepaar
nach kamerun reisen die erfahrungen vom
letzten mal blicken gemischte gefühle
ins gepäck kommen auch schöne kleider
eine kirchliche heirat und eine tafel
stehen an
[Musik]
der große und der kleine prinz warten in
douala auf den besuch aus der schweiz im
gewühle des flughafens findet katharina
ihre eltern die sich verlaufen haben
das ist die neueste anschaffung der
jungen familie 2000 franken hat die
karosse gekostet bar bezahlten keinen
vorschuss des buchverlags da man sich
ist das auto relativ wichtig aber mein
herz und schoss sofort die partie rund
um das spital hat ein heißer tag erlebte
das forum stand der stunden also ss-mann
luxuskarosse bus so etwas wie
lebensrettende maßnahmen erfordert bald
einmal auch das auto diese behauptung
ist wohl nicht übertrieben
[Applaus]
marokko
mit den tücken des fahrzeuges kommen ich
und katharina gut zurecht sagt prinz
basler einfach ist es jedoch nicht
auch die federung ist sportlich
eingestellt was auf diesen straßen
gewisse körperteile stark beansprucht
zum glück ist das ziel nicht mehr fern
hier im westen kameruns und dann mitten
im nirgendwo taucht es auf das haus der
weißen königin und ihres prinzen die
fassade neu gestrichen die zufahrt ist
ausgebaut es hat sich einiges getan seit
unserem letzten besuch
also verbots durchgestrichen
hier heimischen unterhalten oder das
loch und was rechnet sie ja und das ist
ja anrufen
die aufsteiger sagt ding aber wir sind
in afrika trifft das haus stolz ist
willig von basler wissen ja sagte er
es geht aufwärts und weiter ich habe das
meiste selbst gemacht und nun haben wir
einen schönen hof jetzt bin ich ein
richtiger landwirt alles ist besser
geworden
nichts ist mehr wie zuvor und auch
rudolf touch ist glücklich seine welt
ist ein großer roter sandkasten
großvater wenig kann es nicht lassen
der pensionierte handwerker nimmt die
afrikanische bauweise unter die lupe die
sind genau wie und wann nur eine pc
pitstop vor
what's another car uhr der ich sehr
geschätzt weil man sachliche mir selbst
ganz anders zugegeben perfekt ist hier
vieles nicht aber die weiße königin
fühlt sich auf ihrem land wohl neu ist
auch der garten hat weiß man wo man
potenziell jetzt erzähle betrüger häufig
selbst aus es ist einiges besser aus
vorher also mit der ich vorher nie
territorium hill frage und jetzt kann
man kann man sagt er sei es immer noch
knapp mit dem jetzt die kürzlich sie
und wenn ich im garten oder und hier
haben im busch gras dingen unterordnung
zum haus zurück dank diesen zitronen
gibt es seit kurz mal frisches
quellwasser auf dem anwesen
ja das leben ist im vergleich zur
schweiz einfach kein fließendes wasser
kein strom durch im hochland von kamerun
zieht die backstein hütte mit ihren
bescheidenen wohlstand neider an
und dass meine dvd und als dvd grad und
dvds
inzwischen haben sie sich gegen einbruch
gesichert durch magie das ist ein süßes
diebstahl so dass dieser marke
installiert und das bewirkt meiner crew
skype mit danke danke bis staller sobald
das sie verstand einfach berührt und
weißer gaze das seo sem mussawi
blockiert und die youtube lieber so
lange bis wir zurückkommen und bis mir
die person ansprechen
[Musik]
wenn die regeln ort bringt unerwünscht
das ins haus im ebit ist das nass
geworden
[Musik]
an schlaf ist nicht zu denken
die nacht bleibt ungemütlich
schon in aller frühe fact bremsmaßnahmen
heute ist ein besonderer tag
heute reisen gestern für die kirchliche
heirat und die taufe seines sohnes im
inneren der hütte hat so mancher seinen
endgültigen platz noch nicht gefunden
was ich ihr boot besitzen er hat seine
ex diktator ist genau jetzt
jetzt ist es zu erklären dass ich
einfach nur sagen sie passte enorm stark
[Musik]
ihr problem gesundheitlich mit muslimen
naja also verdammt einem bluttest kempka
malaria
[Musik]
die ersten gäste treffen ein
sie kommen von nah und fern
sogar eine journalistin der schweizer
illustrierte nicht eingereicht das ist
theoretisch ein schweizer fahrer der in
kamerun in einer töpferei arbeitet
menschen aus dem busch land bringen holz
für das feuer auf dem das festmahl
zubereitet wird
[Musik]
für katharina ist es schon die dritte
ehe
zuvor war die 43-jährige mit einem
schweizer später mit einem kenianer
verheiratet richtige routiniert im juli
habe die hochzeit mit dem gleicher
machen und jetzt nach hörte warum das
mährische sehr wichtig sie ja immer man
von zeit wenn man als schüler auf
englisch vor gut zwei jahren nur
standesamtlich und mit der ibs gruppe
also sagt grobe 19 ist vor gott und
heimisches fertig basler hat seinen
prinzen kleid angezogen obwohl er nicht
im christlichen glauben aufgewachsen ist
nimmt er gottes segen gerne in empfang
ich bin an ihm ist sagt der prinz ich
habe meine eigene tradition
aber ich glaube an gott
aber schweizer richtig
die gesellschaft ist zusammen getrommelt
was besser um das dem fahrer freut's
denn es wird immer heißer und im
gegensatz zur gesellschaft die im
schatten sitzt steht im schwarzen talar
unter der sonne hochsitz und herrschaft
sowie kaffee von rudolf das ist und von
so genannten rechtlicher rat vom fach
katrin und von marcel rudolf uthoff im
namen von gott diesem vater dem sohn
jesus christus und vom heiligen geist
getauft werden und dann warten alle
gespannt auf das eheversprechen
[Musik]
kathrin versprichst du mit ihm die
wahrheit zusammenlebe gute und
schwierige tage so ins tal und dem treue
zahlen
ich spreche das heißt der kleine lebt
noch voll in der gnade des augenblicks
ich bin ich ganz sicher wie es der wird
werden die sky oder ruhe die welt
bewirkt dass ich habe mich sehr hier
kriegen die wachse die wache eigentlich
mit sehr viel groove und erwartet ihr
sehr gut und das ist gut dass ich noch
so bis wo wir noch beschäftigen
dann trafen die hochzeitsgesellschaft
auf afrikanisch er zu sagen pflegt
andere länder an der umstände
was soll's es geht auch so der
frischgebackene bräutigam hat sich etwas
abgesondert von den anderen gästen
nach dem ersten hält die königin draußen
hof in der hütte findet so etwas wie
eine hochzeits tanz statt
ohne braut dafür mit dem kleinen prinzen
die hatte bezirk für andere mit dem
material des frühjahres wo sie in
kärnten zusammenarbeit wie er der bezirk
die erste große euphorie sport sich was
soll ich einfach verliebt aber es
sicherlich rote platz gemacht weil ich
vor die basis ist durch wer kennt das
nicht auch bei menschen die sich jeden
gibt es manchmal streit es geht um
telefongebühren und geld eine
kleinigkeit jedenfalls ist der ehemann
in seinem stolz verletzt die zipfel
diese szene wie vor auch noch trio zur
shoah regie von trainer schaefer
sessions war princess afrikaner und
rächer status hält und im prinzip um ein
gespräch geben sich prinz um königin in
die haare geraten seien ab und an böse
mächte im spiel
schwarze magie wo du aus dass qualm sie
wollen ganz aus der wodurch ein floß
oder grund ist verstrickt dass net
zwischen zwei manche sondern wo du bist
außerdem floss und es geht gerade heben
wir nicht verstehen
auf dem kultplatz gleich neben dem
grundstück der jungen familie
der höhepunkt der festlichkeiten ist
katharina sohn gewidmet
der voodoo priester beschwört und
symbolische gesten die geister der ahnen
die mächte aus dem jenseits sollen sehen
dass ein kleiner prinz in die welt
gekommen ist und sie sollen ihn vor
bösen einflüssen bewahren
als dank dafür schenkt der 19 monate
alte bub den geistern ein huhn der
glaube versetzt bekanntlich berge
trotzdem scheint die magische
einbruchsicherung noch nicht so richtig
zu funktionieren denn kurz nach unserer
abreise wurde katharinas familie im
eigenen haus überfallen und ausgeraubt
das unheil lässt sich leider nicht immer
vermeiden
auch nicht durch voodoo zauber